there he is aren't those my sunglasses
yeah turns out i need them more than you
do
you know you could have been caught what
would you have done
played dead
[Music]
is oliver
he's a little lonely
see oliver doesn't have any friends
you're weird you're a freak thank you
i'm looking for a friend he had so many
friends he was everybody's friend
[Music]
this is something i really have to do
mitch you understand don't you
here to fix the television set sir
cool shades man
i've never had a family mitch not a real
one
but oliver is about to discover
that family
never dies
young man your daddy's working on the
car go give him a hand
and it's um uh undead come on son
that boy i was definitely up to
something hello there's something very
strange happening in that house making
us look like fools
i think we should go out and party
tonight i've got a date with chloe she
got a sister
mom this is oliver and that's you
mention the car hello
so who is she just a girl i met last
week
i might be dead oliver but i'm not
stupid i've never really had any real
friends
until tonight
[Music]
you're my friend you're going to help me
ollie when have i ever let you down
you're not on your own
[Music]
the loneliest boy in the world
get out of bed you sleepyhead
[Music]
oh dear
what happened here he hit me
she just fell off my bed